es ist der wahnsinn egal wo du hin koks
in diesen tagen krise krise krise doch
zum glück greift jetzt olaf scholz
persönlich ins geschehen ein endlich
kritiker hatten dem kanzler ja
vorgeworfen er wäre zu unsichtbar was
ein seltsamer vorwurf ist denn genau
dafür haben ihn ja eigentlich gewählten
für seine unaufgeregte unsichtbarkeit
aber das war gestern freunde scholz
flieg von einem krisengipfel zum
nächsten und macht so deutschland wieder
zum global player auch in der ukraine
krise ich sage nur 5000 helme haben sich
die ukraine dafür eigentlich schon
angemessen bedankt wir wollen uns
beteiligen aber gegen eine stärkste
eingestellt fermi in die welt der jeremy
wir brauchen waffen
danke für helme aber das ist nie genug
hallo die helme waren das einzige
funktionierende bundeswehr kippen dass
wir haben unsere eigenen soldaten laufen
jetzt mit badekappen wenn es mal war
natürlich kann deutschland nicht als
vermittler im sogenannten normandie
format um frieden bringen und dann einer
konfliktpartei waffen liefern ist ja
logisch gleichzeitig möchten aber auch
ungern als unzuverlässiger
bündnispartner dastehen um genau das zu
verhindern war scholz gerade in
washington und schon auf dem flug dahin
hatten die medien ihre erste sensation
lässt sich im schlabberlook auf dem weg
zum antrittsbesuch in washington er
lässig entspannt im pulli schlabberlook
betont lässig im pulli pullover sein
schlabberpulli schlabberlook im flieger
ganz leger im pulli ein macher ein
macher ein mofa ein shaker meine fresse
er trägt einen mausgrauen pullover
dieses crazy fashion victim reiner pr
move und der funktioniert auch noch olaf
scholz startet gerade eine lockerheit
offensive und so gesehen auch sehr
schade dass keiner den ton mitschneiden
durfte als er da im sexy schlabberlook
im flieger mit den journalisten
geplaudert hat meine vielleicht war es
ja total lustig
hat er erstmal joe biden ist so alt
hatte mit dem zaren verhandelt versteht
ihr wegen lange her
die ukraine krise ist für die amis ja so
was wie ein porsche case szenario
hier glaubt nicht wo ich morgen bin bei
den beiden beiden
so und seine frau die heißen ja beide
beiden live aus dem quatsch comedy
ghetto laughing out loud die neue show
bei amazon prime
[Musik]
memo an mich selber amazon prime
kündigen da kommt genug gemeckert scholz
hat in washington keine ganz schlechte
figur gemacht also außer wenn in einer
gefragt hat ob er im kriegsfall auf nord
stream 2 verzichtet offensichtlich hat
der kanzler eine wette laufen dass er es
schafft bis ostern nicht einmal die
worte nord stream oder zwei zu sagen
wenn man darüber nachdenken wir könnten
die pipeline als signal an die ukraine
einseitig auf eis legen bis die russen
ihre truppen von der grenze abziehen
aber der olaf setzt bei sanktionen halt
auf den faktor überraschung da gibt es
nichts was ausgeschlossen ist das muss
man sehr genau wissen und natürlich
weißrussland auch dass sie sich so
vorstellen können was es alles sein
könnte aber das ist möglicherweise noch
viel mehr ist der putin sitzt den ganzen
tag in seinem palast und denkt ich bin
so gespannt auf die deutsche sektion was
kriege ich wohl mein gott die ganze welt
diskutiert seit wochen über nord stream
2 was soll das denn für eine
überraschung sein eine überraschung ist
per definition überraschend dir das ist
eine überraschung
[Musik]
den blick wollen wir bei putin sehen
übrigens verteidigte scholz mit seinem
nord stream rum gl leider tatsächlich
deutsche interessen denn wir sind halt
viel zu abhängig von russischem gas
wieso junkies über die hälfte unserer
gasimporte kommen aus russland und sind
kurzfristig gar nicht zu ersetzen unter
anderem deswegen neben scholz und seine
leute das böse f-wort nie in den mund
und zwar egal wie oft man sie darum
bittet wir reden über nord stream zwei
sie sagen es jetzt auch wie vor zum 2
dieses ungeheuer um dieses ungeheuer
nehmen weil auch bei ihnen fällt mir auf
nord stream 2
hagen nicht erklären dieses rumgeeiere
um dieses böse wortlos xtreme 2 wenn die
buchschlager lernt so viel und was ist
mit nord stream 2 keine ahnung von sag
das wort klingt weil damit das aufhört
vielleicht sollten wir den lanz mit
putin verhandeln lassen dann gibt er
nach drei minuten entnervt auf im
übrigen hat ja präsident biden bei der
gemeinsamen pk in washington dem olaf
scholz die ganze überraschung schon
kaputt gemacht er ist ja so im
kriegsfall gibt es kein nord stream zwei
basta sagt jo woraufhin eine us
reporterin zu recht fragt ob die amis
uns deutschen einfach so unsere eigene
röhre zu machen dürfen opa meint ja
die kontrolle darüber irgendwie gegen
deutschland kramer
ich darf ihnen versprechen dafür dazu in
der lage sein werden na ja blöd wenn man
so was männlich entschlossenes sagt und
genau dann piept das hörgerät
meinen natürlich verfolgen die
amerikaner hier auch eigene interessen
die sind inzwischen weltgrößter
exporteur von flüssiggas und stellen
ihre öl importe aus russland nie zur
disposition
preisfrage schafft man es noch irgendwie
putin vom einmarsch in die ukraine
abzuhalten kann man nur hoffen ich setze
da ja vor allem auf emanuel makro der
war gerade bei putin in moskau und hat
uns so was wie das bild der woche
geschenkt hier und falls sie sich gerade
fragen gab es denn keinen größeren tisch
ich kann sie beruhigen das ist natürlich
ein aus tisch an genau dem sitz der
nächste woche olaf scholz und schreit
den sieben meter entfernt sitzende putin
an du glaubst nicht was ich schon
überraschung in meinem sanktionspaket
habe lasst mich ort für zwei heiße weißt
du doch oder so ähnlich derweil in der
ukraine in kiew bereiten sie sich
derweil auf den ernstfall vor
freiwillige üben mit attrappen aus
sperrholz oder ganz ohne gewähr die
unsichtbaren gewehre haben übrigens wir
deutschen geliefert zusammen mit der
unsichtbaren munition und noch mal es
ist richtig dass wir keine waffen
schicken wäre übrigens in seiner
dreistigkeit im moment fast schon
respekt ab nötig ist gerd schröder an
alter was für ein timing ausgerechnet
jetzt zieht er wohl auch noch in den
aufsichtsrat von gazprom ein er selbst
ja schon in dem der nord stream ag und
dem von rosneft aber davon alleine
kannst ja nicht leben allerdings kämpft
der altkanzler nicht alleine für die
pipeline da oben die landesregierung von
mecklenburg vorpommern unter konsolen
schwesig kämpft tapfer mit wir schalten
live vor das schweriner schloss da
veranstaltet nord stream nämlich eine
kleine feierstunde gerade singt wohl ein
shanty-chor wir hören mal rein eine
pipeline durch die ostsee ja das ist
doch nie verkehrt wenn die macht uns
alle reiche nicht so lässt den schultern
[Musik]
bravo herzlichen dank an unseren
shantychor die warnemünder erdgas
schnüffler toll meine damen und herren
ich bin stolz und glücklich ihn heute
mitteilen zu dürfen dass die regierung
hier in schwerin endlich der umbenennung
ihres bundeslandes zugestimmt hat
mecklenburg vorpommern heißt ab sofort
mecklenburg vorpommern powered by nord
stream 2 es ist ein bisschen sperrig ich
weiß kinder wir fahren an die ostsee
nach mädchen pogromen powered by nord
stream 2 aber jedem der weiter den alten
namen benutzt werden unsere anwälte den
arsch aus der hose klagen so gibt es
noch fragen ihrerseits oliver welke zdf
news warum lässt sich denn meck pomm von
russland kaufen also diese unterstellung
weise ich entschieden zurück natürlich
sponsert nord stream hier unzählige
kulturstätten festivals und sportvereine
sowie das usedomer musikfestival daher
die kunsthalle rostock das baltic sea
philharmonic orchestra die frauen
volleyball mannschaft ssc palenberg in
schwerin aber
gibt es noch andere fragen ja hier
andrea kiewel zdf fernsehgarten sie
finde es also auch gar nicht
problematisch dass eine stiftung des
landes mit russischem geld den fertigbau
der röhre vor sanktionen geschützt hat
und die nennt man dann auch noch
stiftung klima und umweltschutz die
wirklich die pipeline bauen und auch
nicht betreiben sie kann einen kleinen
beitrag leisten die pipeline zu
unterstützen unser schwerpunkt liegt auf
der förderung der klima und umwelt
projekte tja und was ist denn besser
fürs klima als noch mehr gas also
manchmal nein nein alles wird gut jetzt
mit gerd schröder im gazprom
aufsichtsrat an dieser stelle vielleicht
auch mal ein herzliches dankeschön an
den deutschen steuerzahler dass man ist
dem altkanzler
ermöglicht aus einem von ihnen allen
finanzierten büro heraus für russland zu
lobbyieren das ist ein ganz feiner zug
wladimir putin wird das nicht vergessen
und für einen nagel fritzen hier nochmal
unser lieblings gas vertreter zum thema
rosneft das ist der weltgrösste
erdölkonzern mitte wirklich wichtigen
beziehungen zu deutschland und
deswegen habe ich überhaupt gar kein
problem damit und denke auch gar nicht
darin mehr uns machen zu lassen eier aus
stahl und zwar aus russischem stahl so
ich denke damit habe ich all ihre
bedenken ausgeräumt und freue mich jetzt
noch mal riesig auf unseren shantychor
nein entschuldigung unseren kosaken chor
aus warnemünde
eine pipeline ist so lang macht uns und
heizung an
den putin eine pipeline ist so groß ich
gehe bis der teufel los
die haben gesagt die soll meinen
lieblings witz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein pferd chef base
und der papst in eine bar sagt der
barkeeper
abonnier endlich den zwei takten heute
schon kanal also geht doch